[Music]
on this Friday night two detained
Canadians officially charged in China
new fears over the faith's of the two
Michaels
Ottawa's response and the criticism
against Prime Minister Trudeau
investigating despicable behavior at BC
hospitals serious allegations of racist
and completely abhorrent practices the
offensive game some health care workers
are accused of playing the Juneteenth
marches take on new meaning the rallies
across Canada and the US and from remote
to removed the bus that was all the fuss
[Music]
moves on
global national would Donna Friesen
reporting tonight
Robin Gill good evening and thank you
for joining us we begin with a major
development in the case of the two
Michaels
five hundred and fifty seven days after
Michael Kovarik and Michael SPAWAR were
detained in China
prosecutors have now charged them with
spine
it's an apparent move to pressure Ottawa
to drop an extradition case against
Huawei executive hmong wong jo the two
men have been detained since December
2018 and they could face life in prison
but as Eric Sorenson reports the
Canadian government is trapped in a
diplomatic dispute with an internal
legal deadline approaching China finally
late charges against two Canadians see
social jacuz Makonnen both are accused
of spying on state secrets for overseas
interests michael Kovarik and michael
spar have been held in harsh conditions
for 18 months they were seized in China
just days after Chinese executive for
huawei hmong wong jo was detained by
Canadian authorities at the request of
the United States we have continued to
express our disappointment with the
Chinese decision the Prime Minister
expressed concern for the two men and
they're worried families suggesting the
Chinese have linked the two Michaels to
Hmong Juan Jose detention here there
obviously are no links except in
politics on that so we will continue to
ask the Chinese and put pressure on the
Chinese government to cease the
arbitrary detention of these two
Canadian citizens the opposition says
the Prime Minister isn't standing up to
China and I think what we see from this
government is a certain weakness and I
have a say when it comes to approaching
the government of China Justin Trudeau
has resisted calls to increase economic
pressure and public outrage this former
ambassador to China says that has to
change the only language that China
understand is one of firmness but
raising the temperature with the Chinese
risks setting back a diplomatic solution
I think it's important that we've
reached the phase of trying not to
escalate tensions
but to manage them critics accused the
Chinese of hostage diplomacy you do not
who will win Canada don't rule when
asked the Chinese official tersely
responded asked the Canadian government
about hostage diplomacy tree duty
neither side the official level would
like to frame it as such because that
isn't going to help us in a resolution
Ottawa is ramping up pressure on the
Chinese to grant the two Canadians
consular access it was suspended in
January say the Chinese because of the
pandemic Eric Sorensen Global News
Toronto China's Intelligence Agency is
accused of a sophisticated state-based
cyber attack against the Australian
government security experts say it's
likely payback for banning Huawei from
the country's 5g network and after
Australia demanded an independent
inquiry into China's handling of Cova 19
the hacks which have been happening for
months have targeted health and
education departments as well as
political organizations a Chinese
spokesperson says the communist
government is firmly opposed to all
forms of cyber attacks we know
extremists hate is on the rise in Canada
and tonight a new report puts it in
perspective a London based think tank
with funding from the Canadian
government found close to 7,000 channels
of right-wing extremism and as Abigail
Beeman reports the haters are operating
with obscurity on the Internet
what do the 2019 federal election and
the Christchurch mosque attack have in
common a new report shows they both
caused spikes in Canadian right-wing
extremist activity online the report
from the Institute for Strategic
Dialogue or ISD with funding from the
Canadian government looked at seven
platforms from Facebook Twitter and
YouTube
two fringe outlets including the
now-defunct fascist Forge there is
really this fairly well-established
infrastructure of right-wing extremist
communities operating across these
different platforms ISD found nearly
7,000 right-wing extremist pages groups
users and channels in Canada with a wide
reach 11 million users worldwide but it
is sort of normalizing those narratives
especially where they're on the
mainstream platforms right that somehow
if it's on Facebook it's on Twitter
barbara perry published Canada's first
national study on right-wing extremism
back in 2015 the new ISD study is part
of her broader update that will look at
offline activity - if you look at two of
the most extreme platforms for example
the iron March and the fascist Forge
Canada ranks up there in the top three
with the US and the UK in terms of
active members so I think that that will
come as a real surprise anti-muslim
hostility and hatred were among the most
common topics they really suggest that
there is a concerted effort by Canadians
to target Canadian Muslims to say that
they're not welcome in this country and
even to justify attacks against them
anti Trudeau rhetoric is very prevalent
- here's one example of a post on
Fortune's politically incorrect page
other categories analyzed include white
supremacy and the manosphere a catch-all
for misogynist movements like in cells
and while social media may only be
online it allows extremists to spread
propaganda recruit and coordinate
activity including violence extremists
are also starting to target Chinese
people blaming them for the novel
coronavirus Perry believes the full 2020
data will show much more hate in general
with so many people at home online
because the anxiety caused by COBIT more
people are perhaps looking for
these kinds of outlets these kinds of
narratives and conspiracy theories and
in the wake of the most recent
anti-racist protests ISD is also
starting to document evidence of groups
targeting black people to Abigail in
this fight against hate who is
ultimately responsible well Robin
experts say government law enforcement
and social media platforms all have a
role but so do we to call things out and
report them when we see them Facebook
tells us in the first quarter of 2020
they removed close to 10 million posts
under hate speech policies and as for
the government the Public Safety
Minister's Office says they're committed
to taking action to stop terrorism
violence and hate linked to the online
world and pointed us to a campaign
promise to make social media platforms
remove illegal content within 24 hours
or face consequences but no details
about when the Liberals would implement
that or how Robin
Abigail Beeman in Ottawa an
investigation has been launched into
disturbing allegations that er staff at
hospitals in BC have been playing a game
called The Price is Right where they
guessed the blood alcohol level of
mainly indigenous patients the provinces
healthcare minister is just as outraged
as health advocates Global BC
sweat-resistant is following this story
tonight Richard do we know where this
game was being played and how widespread
it is those are some of the big
questions Robin and we still don't know
the answers Health Minister Adrienne Dix
was informed of these allegations last
night and he moved quickly to try to get
answers an investigation has now been
launched it will be led by Mary Ellen
terpil Lafont the former representative
of children youth here in British
Columbia and a very well-known member of
the indigenous community but this is
much larger there are still questions
around how often did this happen did it
happen in multiple facilities does it
involve ER doctors and nurses and other
staff and exactly where in British
Columbia all of this has unfolded
indigenous communities in British
Columbia have raised concerns in the
past around systemic racism in the
healthcare system
that has been representative in a few
reports and the government now is moving
towards action to figure out some of
these issues I was made aware of serious
allegations of racist and abhorrent
practices in an emergency room or
emergency rooms in British Columbia if
confirmed the conduct is beyond
unacceptable hopefully there will be
some change and not just more words when
it comes to reducing racism within our
healthcare system when you bring it down
to the front line it means that that
that maytee people other indigenous
peoples across the province are not
getting the health care that they
deserve they're not getting the kind of
health care they need premier John
Horgan sending out a statement on this
calling the incident ugly and anti
indigenous racism and that the
investigator and all this Mary Ellen
Terp elefante will have the full support
of government there's no timeline yet
Robin on when this investigation will be
completed but they do have that support
of government to do it Richard Sussman
in Victoria BC thanks Richard Marwan
tabara the Liberal MP accused of assault
and criminal harassment made a brief
court appearance via videoconference
today tavera was first elected as a
Liberal MP for Kitchener South Hezbollah
in 2015 in April this year he was
arrested in Guelph the Prime Minister
has said he and his office only learned
about the charges
two months later today Global News asked
Justin Trudeau why there was a delay
between the time tabara was charged at a
time his office found out there is a
apparently a rule in the House of
Commons Standing Orders that if a member
of parliament is arrested the speaker or
the house needs to be officially
informed that rule has apparently not
been followed or applied much over the
past year it is certainly disappointing
as as a party leader that the individual
in question never chose to inform the
party of which he was a part of these
charges tabara is still serving as an MP
but has stepped away from the Liberal
caucus he has not yet entered
a plea the federal Conservative Party
held its second leadership debate last
night this time in English it was mostly
a duel between the frontrunners Peter
MacKay and Aaron O'Toole
but as our chief political correspondent
David akin reports they'll still need
support from the other contenders to
determine who gets the top job the
leader in the race to succeed
Andrew Shearer is the party's co-founder
Peter MacKay I've worked with Stephen
Harper I've worked with social
conservatives fiscal conservatives
across the spectrum in fact I don't
speak of true-blue I speak of everyone
when I speak of the Conservative Party
no hyphenated conservatives let's all
get behind a conservative plan and a
leader who can win but Ontario MP Aaron
O'Toole is nipping at McKay's heels it's
time for a true-blue conservative who
can win the next election and get our
country back on track but neither McCain
or O'Toole are believed to have enough
votes to win the leadership on the first
ballot which means they have to appeal
to supporters of the other two
candidates Leslie Lewis is a Toronto
lawyer who has never held office and
Derek Sloan is a first term Ontario MP
both are social conservatives social
conservatism is a very very important
part of our party and we can't be afraid
to address values the Liberals are so
radically far to the left and their
ideas when it comes to conversion
therapy and abortion that we can gain
ground on these ideas Sloan's agenda may
be too radical for relative moderates
like O'Toole or McKay but both clearly
signaled Thursday night that they are
keen to bring Lewis and her supporters
to their camps I agree with dr. Lewis's
discussion around manufacturing I agree
with a lot of what dr. Lewis said it's
still not yet clear how much of a social
conservative bent McKay or O'Toole would
incorporate into their platforms to win
but O'Toole said it's vital his party do
better to meet voter expectations on
climate change the environment is
critical for our children and for voters
if we want to win in the suburbs of
Canada the next time we have to have a
real plan Conservative Party members get
their ballots by the end of July and
must have them back to the party by
August 21st with the winner to be
announced soon Ave
David akin Global News Ottawa police in
Brampton Ontario are investigating a
horrific crash that killed a mother and
her three young daughters it happened
yesterday afternoon police say a vehicle
hit the family's SUV the 37 told mom and
her children all under the age of six
died Brampton's mayor Patrick Brown
shared this video on social media that
appears to show a blue vehicle seemingly
out of control on Tuesday Brown alleges
it's the same vehicle involved in
yesterday's fatal crash the mayor calls
the driver a brazen repeat offender with
no regard for human life
alleging he had a prohibited licence for
multiple driving offences nothing can
ever reconcile the loss for this family
the only thing that I hope to see is is
justice I believe this is criminal
negligence causing death it's murder and
this person belongs behind bars the 20 L
driver of the car survived the crash
Ontario Special Investigations Unit has
been called in at this point no charges
have been laid a major rally for the US
president presses ahead during the
pandemic coming up what his supporters
will have to do if they want to go
hundreds of thousands of people across
North America are finding different ways
to honor
Juneteenth also known as Freedom Day in
Toronto thousands of people staged a
sit-in calling for the Toronto Police
Service to be defunded Juneteenth
commemorates the day all enslaved people
in the u.s. learned they had been freed
this year has taken on new meaning in
large part to the recent deaths of black
Americans in the u.s. capital dozens of
people mark the day by marching to the
Martin Luther King memorial in support
of black lives matter and in New York
several marches and events took place
across the city calling for an end to
racial injustice 'as a Juneteenth event
is also taking place at this hour in
Tulsa Oklahoma it comes just hours ahead
of a controversial Donald Trump camp
rally in the city nearly 20,000 Trump
supporters are expected to pack into an
enclosed arena tomorrow despite fears
the event could turn into a kovat 19
super spreader Jackson prosecco reports
they've been camped out for days outside
Tulsa's BOK Center hoping for a spot at
the first Trump campaign rally since the
pandemic began I'm not any more
concerned about the corona virus in the
BOK than I am in Walmart they're
expecting a full house of 20,000 on
Saturday with Trump supporters standing
shoulder-to-shoulder no physical
distancing here attendees will be given
masks but won't be required to wear them
it's a personal choice I won't be
wearing a mask but anyone going will
have to sign a liability waiver saying
they won't sue if they get sick the
courts rejected a lawsuit seeking to
force public health measures I'm as
concerned about the virus as I am about
every yearly flu public health experts
warn it's a disaster in the making a
potential super spreader event in a
state where case numbers are rising by
record numbers daily it's truly
inexplicable because such a is such an
event is really the last thing that
should be occurring during a pandemic
moving the rally to an outdoor venue
would ease some of those concerns but
the Trump campaign has refused even that
basic step we're gonna be in Oklahoma
and it's a crowd like I guess nobody's
seen before in an interview with The
Wall Street Journal the president
admitted some of his supporters might
catch the virus but said it's a very
small percentage let me be clear
anyone planning to attend a large-scale
gathering will face an increased risk of
becoming infected with Koba 19 that
hasn't swayed the campaign the president
has been anxious to return to his
rallies and he's unlikely to back down a
second time after the criticism he faced
for originally scheduling his event in
Tulsa site of the worst race Massacre in
American history on Juneteenth a day
marking the end of slavery
Jaxson cross go Global News Washington
still ahead their lips are sealed but
they have the ticket to fun in Japan
Malala yousufzai who was targeted by the
Taliban for pursuing an education has
completed her degree at Oxford
University the 22 year old posted these
images of her celebration this morning
she completed a degree in philosophy
politics and economics in 2012 she was
shot while returning home from school in
Pakistan in 2014 she was given the Nobel
Peace Prize today she tweeted I don't
know what's ahead for now it will be
Netflix breeding and sleep well done
theme parks are reopening in Japan as
kovat 19 restrictions ease but there's a
new twist
screaming is not allowed on
rollercoasters and the video you're
about to see shows it can be done these
are the top bosses of Japan's most
popular amusement park appearing more
concerned about their masks slipping and
their hair moving the parks say the
change is to help prevent the spread of
the virus through saliva but for thrill
seekers who just can't help themselves
there are no penalties the wheels on
this bus go up and down up next a legend
gets a lift to the next stop
back when we were allowed to travel
there were places in popular movies that
really pull people in like the Iowa farm
in field of dreams or the bridge in Hope
BC from first blood certain landmarks
are a major draw for tourists but as
Mike Armstrong explains one attraction
that was way off the grid in a remote
corner of Alaska proved to be far too
popular what a feeling to be circling
and approaching this is a video made
last summer by two friends out of
Edmonton a trip to Alaska they dreamt
about for years with the goal of
reaching this spot I see it what pulls
people to this old abandoned bus is the
story of Chris McCandless he found it
hiking in 1992 took this picture and was
never able to make it out of the
wilderness he starved to death inside
McCandless's journey inspired a
best-selling novel into the wild later
turned into a movie it's the story of
what led McCandless to head out and what
he found he left behind a diary and
notes that included a quote that was
carved into a plaque bahlika happiness
is only real when shared that's true
when Chris ended up at that bus I've got
to say that is one of the most beautiful
places I've ever been this Chris
McCandless on the scene position is not
now the tale of the solitary Trek and
lonely death went around the world it
frustrated some but inspired others the
book's author says some people see an
idiot some people see themselves he was
not crazy he was just trying to clear
his head of things that happened when he
was growing up McCandless his sister
shared those memories this was her in
2014 over the years many have hiked to
the bus in fact as it turns out too many
Alaskan authorities this week took the
into the wild bus out of the wild they
had to make more than a dozen rescues
over the last decade one woman was
killed last summer they're going to move
it somewhere safer they haven't decided
where thanks Magic Bus good ride Ryan
Lester says he hopes it ends up
somewhere people can visit it without
the same danger it's surreal but feeling
the same presence my Karma global news
and that is global national for this
Friday I'm Robin Gill tonight your
Canada is Petrolia Ontario where they
were planting the last of the soybeans
we'd love to see your corner of this
country so email your pictures to
viewers at global national calm thank
you for watching and I'll see you back
here tomorrow good night
[Music]
you